you
newly released video shows an American
aid worker racing into gunfire to save a
little girl in Iraq the dangerous rescue
was carried out by David Ewbank who runs
a humanitarian group free Burma Rangers
you spent the last nine months with
Iraqi forces for attacking the Isis
stronghold of Mosul Jamie you can spoke
with him when he returned to the United
States she's in Los Angeles now Jamie
good morning Gail you bank will not call
himself a hero but what he did is truly
heroic his mission in Mosul isn't just
about helping people as an aid worker
it's also about documenting life they're
on video what he captured on camera
earlier this month was like nothing he
had ever experienced before
here is huge a sister trying to move
people as an aid worker in Mosul Iraq
David Ewbank is used to being confronted
by civilian deaths but recently he came
upon a scene that was especially
horrific I see what turns out to me
about 70 dead bodies women children guys
in wheelchairs shot dead in wheelchairs
and then in the middle of that carnage
he saw something truly heartbreaking I
see movement and then a little girl
sitting next to her dead mother hiding
under hip the black hijab like this and
it looks goes like this despite
continued attacked by Isis snipers
Ewbank says he had to try to rescue her
smoke drop by Allied forces and
firepower from Iraqi soldiers gave him
the cover he needed I thought you know
if I'm killed my wife and kids will
understand this is not bravado this is
not adventure this is trying to save
somebody the rescue took just 12 seconds
the little girl was safe
it's believed her entire family was
killed why did you do it
love and I remembered this scripture
greater love has no man he lay down his
life for me and you know when you're out
of your own strength
for me I ask God help me Eubanks family
is aware of the dangers in fact his wife
and three children were there in Mosul
choosing to be with him as he continues
his humanitarian mission his 16 year old
daughter Sahay Lee helped comfort the
girl after her rescue your dad told us
that you said that if he didn't come
back you would understand it's well it's
because we all prayed about it and
imagine if like if one of your kids was
out there and being shot by Isis
wouldn't you want someone else to go out
there and save them so we're doing this
for love Eubanks family of five is now
on a break in Washington State
where the sounds of the ranch have
replaced the sounds of gunfire what do
you like about being here I like it here
because most the time you're not really
like worried about I was Isis right over
there like am I gonna go outside get
shot or anything kinda like that the
little girl hasn't spoken since the
attack Iraqi soldiers are searching for
any living relatives if they can't find
anyone Eubank says a local general and
his wife are willing to adopt her
Ewbank plans to continue his work
returning to Iraq and a couple of weeks
along with his family we're not Superman
or superwoman but we can do something
and the families are still in trouble
people coming out probably about every
day trying to get out sometimes they're
shot sometimes they're not we can we can
help you make knows what he's doing is
dangerous work but he says as a man of
faith he believes it's necessary for he
and his family to continue doing it as
for the little girl he plans to check on
her when he returns to Mosul he wants to
remain in her life forever
Nora Jamie thank you what an incredible
inner of me they will be bonded forever
but what a guy and what an example he's
setting for the idea that one person can
make a difference yeah great